essaie de reproduire des scènes de notre
ville il y a une cinquantaine d'années
est là ce sont des gens qui s'y greffent
des iris ont pour les manger la
nostalgie mais oui peut-être oui oui on
verra c'est fini ce temps là on ne
reverra plus ah
oui enfin
maintenant tout est changé évidemment
on est peut-être
un peu plus argentés que dans le temps
on n'est pas plus heureux
ce qu'on a perdu une certaine liberté
le loyer souk en là c'est un camp est
entouré
mais tout de même ça ne vaut pas quand
même la nature seront pas une belle
place d'herbe avec des beaux-arts ont
été pour se détendre sourit à peine
quelques peupliers m'enfin y'a paderne
les tziganes sont restés un peuple se
condamnant au voyage et gardant dans
leurs bagages le bio langage indien
mystérieux deegan qui ont réussi à
passer les siècles les royaumes les
embûches des sédentaires les crématoires
nazis sans perdre en route les arts de
travailler le cuivre de tresser losier
et de faire chanter les guitares mais
pour combien de temps encore depuis
quelques années beaucoup s'adonnent
commerce itinérant leur spécialité c'est
le porte-à-porte vêtements un chiffon
sous le bras
[Musique]
maintenant on a commencé comme à
s'intéresser à s'intéresser à l'argent
pas pour l'admirer mais pour ce qu'il
peut nous procurer et une envie d'une
voiture les jeunes ont envie de voitures
de belles voitures maintenant sont comme
les autres alors maintenant on fait
attention
essayait bien de l'argent pour vous pour
se procurer ce que l'on désire avoir
vous êtes envahis par la société de
consommation est obligé de suivre le
mouvement maintenant y'a pas concernée
nous oblige à 2 donc je suis vous ne
pensez pas que les enfants finiront par
devenir sédentaire
mentalité gratuitement jamais de la vie
contraint et forcé par la force des
choses là vraiment donc j'ai travaillé
peut-être mais là on aime passer du
travail pour aller travailler en usine
de leur plein gré
sinon à petit vous mais voilà
profitez d'un endroit là
profitez-en
voilà nos cadeaux là j'ai pas comme dans
les mammouths la halle ont dépouillé
les familles gitanes
[Musique]
la famille gitane
c'est une famille une grande famille une
famille comme les autres en somme qui
sont mal connus et très mal appréciée
parce que chez nous n'est pas dans les
gens du voyage il n'y a pas le déjeuner
de gens il ya aussi des voleurs
mais si on prend les gens de la ville
les voyous qui attaquent les petites
vieilles et puis tout c'est pas des
gitans mais sur le journal il n'ya pas
encore ces saloperies gitans ne soyez
pas maintenant maintenant on est nous on
est mal mal apprécié la fidélité joué un
grand rôle dans le couple gitans
bas en principe après ses fruits
tulle ac et marié normalement et ben si
la femme est pas fidèle et alors il se
fait reboot de la tête 7e vaut
pas grand chose au score
vous avez 19 ans est ce que vous pouvez
sortir le soir non
non non j'ai pas droit
comment comment si vous connaissez un
jeune homme par exemple comment
arrivez-vous elle fréquentait son épais
c'est à dire que si je rencontre un
jeune homme nos jours qu'il veut
vraiment fréquenté sérieusement faut
qu'ils viennent trouver le papa croix
et vous avez vous aimeriez poussée
dentaire pas du tout non aux lilas
pourquoi parce que c'est pas la même
mentalité
vous nous expliquez bien pour mieux
avancer le caractère et deuxièmement un
travail est différente de notre
cercle sédentaires bon lui il faut
qu'ils valent usine faut qu'il travaille
tandis que nous bon on va travailler le
matin et l'après midi on est libre alors
nous c'est ça qui nous et qui compte
pour nous c'est la liberté mais le
travail si lanternes en général chez moi
on ne se marie pas ne se marie pas un
jeune homme soit une jeune fille les
parents on le sait ouais ils sont bons
pour commencer et ils vont passer
quelques jours ensemble évidemment dans
une chambre évidemment ça se passe parce
que le corps d'où ils reviennent
quelques jours à boîte on fait alors
laissons marié et c'est terminé pour
quelquefois y en a qui passent devant le
maire après mais c'est déjà fait et
quand ils ont nourri la risée la
situation à la radio pour les enfants ta
liberté dans le couple comment la
concerne tous
alors
liberté dans le groupe
et vous
la liberté dans le couple
exactement ce qu'on peut appeler liberté
dans le trouble parce que chacun est pas
libre un couple
si la femme est libre et à l'arel
c'était un jules si l'homme est libre il
fait de manas alors là c'est pas pareil
c'est à dire que chez nous une fois
qu'on est marié on reste on est bon a
expliqué sa
combinaison voilà
pour toutes les fois marié s'est classé
x et alors est ce qu'il est possible de
connaître un jeune homme point d'une
fille
ben c'est pas trop ma demain parce que
le pape à avoir claire aussi et puis on
a tous des fusils c'est ça qui c'est
très embêtant c'est très embêtant
la pureté défense est primordial
oui normalement
[Musique]
la présence sas évolué il ya du
changement
va il reste encore beaucoup de jeunes
filles drop quand elles se marient
voudriez ressembler à une jeune fille
sédentaires qui peut sortir avant de se
marier ah non pas du tout
j'aime mieux être comme je suis
[Musique]
les enfants c'est la continuité de la
race
oui
oui parce que ça une femme par exemple
qui se marie avec
[Musique]
non gitans quoi mais c'est rare si ça va
bien
avant ce sont des petits rois des grands
seigneurs même dans les quarante-huit
obéissent bien souvent
les enfants font ce qu'ils veulent ici
vous voyez les enfants sont ce qu'ils
veulent ils courent de tous les côtés
l'ont perpétrée hier mais
rien à faire et pourtant c'est vers
l'âge de 15 16 ans que les filles n'ont
plus le droit de faire ce qu'elle veut
mais ce disque est une fille voilée
tconcert une fille elle peut avoir
l'accident le garçon ces différentes
l'exercice tout à fait normal pour moi
c'est normal et fille qui attend un bébé
sans être mariés
[Musique]
immédiatement
son peuple ont des systèmes étrangers
c'est un étranger mais ça c'est déjà
arrivé ça fait du bruit
li
nuit
si vous m'avez regardez vous avez bien
vu j'ai commencé par le nom ni
le nomma des lettres du moment de
l'instant d'où son engouement pour la
télévision blanc photo et sa méfiance
devant l'écriture qui fixe et en faire
le paon ses idées l'école suppose en
définitive le choix pour la civilisation
sous-entraînés ciné cool et peut-être la
fin du voyage et il a un autre nom ça
s'appelle
[Musique]
l'amour la joie
mais la paix
et m
il fonda politiques libéraux j'en ai
jamais vu qu'il faisait de la politique
alors là non
n'ai jamais entendu parler de politique
chez nous alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont
comme préoccupation actuelle spirituelle
intellectuelle
vous savez
tout est chez nous il y en a pas
beaucoup qui n'a très peu elle même pas
du tout
en réalité toutes les digues à nice où
tout catholique
[Musique]
c'est tous les catholiques et ben il ya
environ vous dis bien c'est le cinquième
mis sur 208 voyez combien qui reste
environ 185 millions qui sont
catholiques qu'est ce que c'est que les
pentecôtistes
pas le coach ça se trouve dans la ville
donc c'est l'apôtre pierre qui l'est
tout est dit si puissants 120 dans une
chambre haute le seigneur a dit vous
attendez ici vous recevez le spécial qui
descendra du ciel qui vous remplira de
l'esprit de dieu est ce cet esprit ben
il est tombé sur nous ou eux mêmes je
suis baptisera cet esprit et je peux
vous dire une chose que seigneur a dit
que dans les derniers temps qui
rassemblera un peuple sans instruction
qui se trouve au carrefour des routes
inondées et en réalité ce sont évidents
il a guéri mes enfants m'a dit qu'il
n'aurait pas dû être nés à la naissance
vous la sauvez je suis content de lui
appartenir aujourd'hui de la radio
ma chère
tu di gio ponti fait chier quoi tu puis
sauvé maintenant
est ce que tu veux je suis pas bon je
condamne et bombay jours oui alors sur
la confession de tapuach se baptisent au
nom du père du fils et du saint-esprit
[Musique]